Danny is lovely to see you here today
our last time we spoke was before season
3 came out and since then your
characters how she say gained a little
bit of a reputation and a nickname on
the interwebs called tripod how do you
feel about that I I feel feel just like
any guy who is playing a character who
apparently has a magic penis would feel
very less
it's great it's absolutely great the
whole world thinks I'm a sex god oh it's
gone from this shy guy to save your
Tyrion to super stirred over the seasons
so I wonder what you enjoyed most about
that transformation and what do you
think about it I don't know for me at
the nicest thing about season 3 was just
how the relationship between Teddy and
blonde and pod grew and how they grew as
a trio and you didn't got to see that by
that stage
pardon blonde are the only people that
ted ian has and he but he starts relying
more than more than partners as as the
third season goes on which which is just
it's nice you know it's nice to talk
with gentleman Peter Moore it's nice to
work with you're all on his own it's
nice to look repeated on his own and it
was just it was nice to have a bit more
to get my teeth on to know some great
scene Stephanie and what everyone's of
course wanting at this I've got to ask
you is why did the ladies love pod
sandwich and to criterion we're going to
need details copious details I just I
don't I don't know I've been thrown all
these crazy theories that apparently
he's been talking he just talked to them
and he was really kidding in general and
that's why and then all that stuff about
how Littlefinger might have peed them
off or whatever I don't know I just
think it was about better late relief I
think people are thinking about it far
too much
I just think that it was you know so
sure but a lot of people died let's have
a fun with some of the good case why not
need a bit here in there especially the
red wedding I mean what do you think
when you saw that scene it was amazing
woman and I I knew I was coming
obviously and I just found that I
thought the internet reaction was the
best part of it I thought that was just
incredible how her how much had people
really seemed to affect a lot of
people's lives and quite a significant
way and that's an incredible episode the
television you know and such a ballsy
thing it do
you've got mainstay characters who you
know everybody expected to go the
distance or to go further and gone great
puts the whole thing on its head which
has you know healthy shakes things up
you never know any moments up on Game of
Thrones do you what do you think it
takes to stay alive in that world and
you think pods got what it takes and yes
yes I do I think I think a magic penis
helps and you talk yourself out of many
a situation baby don't you talk about a
cure solve a very situation sorry
um yeah no I think he does he's smart
you know he's a westerner just because
he doesn't talk much doesn't mean he's
stupid and I think a lot of people make
their well and the show anyway you know
Cersei and and people like people like
that they make a judgment that he's dull
and he's damn and he's not at all he's
he's very astutely lessons he lands he
just doesn't know a flake most other
folk that he's very very clever I think
I think projects are very clever gay did
you have kind of things in mind the way
you're playing him now that you've kind
of kept in reserve little kind of
nuances and things that you think will
come out later or that for you make the
difference of how people perceive him do
you think I have been doing certain
things that I imagine some folk of
notice this physicality is
you know usually very closed off but
when these that only certain people that
comes he opens up a wee but and I don't
know I think that I think that project
maybe act the way it does anyways
because he doesn't want to give anything
away about himself
and that's a smart thing to do you know
everybody thinks you're stupid then let
them think you're stupid you're not a
threat if you're daft so keep yourself
to yourself in that world I think you
have to don't you huge you put money on
coming out on top you think it's going
to be Starks on Lannister's Targaryen
someone else completely and you would
actually but they wants the Starks to
one must be serious
they are the good guys and I think I
think it's you know donatus is going to
sort it all out
I think that's what's going to happen
and maybe it'll be some helpful Starks
governor to be hand along the way but
who knows who knows I would like to see
that I think that would be cool but
again when you in rincón recently in
Germany weren't you and you said you
think the person who most deserves to be
on the throne is Brienne why do you
think that I she's so cool she's so cool
um amazing character Gwen as an amazing
women you know she's an amazing actress
yeah I think I think Breanna's she has
one of the good guys very simply she has
one of the good guys and but she's not
she's not shy it's Hwang Assad
so if need be then she'll get the job
done if you could give pod some advice
for the future what would you tell him
keep an you chose us and I don't know I
have a lot more confidence in yourself I
would say don't yeah
I have a lot more confidence in yourself
he's a good guy
definitely I mean we love him and you're
great as him obviously but I mean if you
could have been any other character in
the show who do you pick any other
character on the show
virus virus maybe that's all that are so
many virus
Jimmy Lannister you know Arya Stark
playin like doesn't my other gender to
these parts that old thing so many of
them aren't credible with credible parts
and that I think that's there's the
great thing about the show is that each
gallic that has their own thing going on
aside from the story they've all got
their own thing going on and that that's
what makes it such a broad abroad thing
I think we talked a bit about how no
one's safe on the show and obviously we
don't want to lose pod anytime soon but
if you had to get the chop on the show
how would you like to meet your maker
don't often think about how I would like
a day and then orally I like to go out
swinging I think I would like to go out
swag enough that was a fair efforts to
go that way I would I would like him to
go out and I do like kick-ass fate may
be proved that the spear through the
back of the head wasn't a fluke who
enormous never big to do that
I mean who have you seen so far in the
death who do you think God that was
pretty awesome that was amazing way to
do that and whose death was good and
Viserys is I think that's you know
that's one of the most creative death
scenes and television yesterday it's
just incredible and Roderick assails
death scene I thought that whole
sequence was you know one of the most
hardhat and powerful moments of the
entire show
great great scene and Ned's death again
you know it's you can't you can't you
can't forget that
I don't know I don't know lots and lots
to choose from I suppose I mean have you
found going back and shooting for season
four compared to the previous seasons
that you had so far is it the I suppose
the longer you spend on anything it just
becomes more and more familiar and you
know as no as it's like a home away from
home for me now I go on it's my third
season on the show and you know I know
everybody there everybody knows me
they're going to do your job go home
it's great it's really really as it's
always been a nice experience for me but
I am but unknown nails ananthan anymore
that so it's all really comfortable and
relaxed and that's what you want it your
work had you seen it but you were caught
on camera in Iceland with Gwen Christy
as Brienne in costume what do you have
to say about that young man
I was I was in Iceland during a photo
shoot that's why I was there
there wasn't any filming event from
taking place I was doing a photo shoot
in Iceland so sadly those rumors are
gonna have to be put to bed we were
standing outside having a cigarette
together if you could have any character
who could have a reality TV show of
their own from Game of Thrones who would
it be and why and what would it involve
and bran definitely because I think he'd
be a diva
I think he's liking the guy who dinner
he'd be the sogno gala Colleen Gallagher
tape yay
but there'll be a lot of tantrums I
think that would be it would be
interesting to see what he interesting
or twisted to see what whatever he gets
up to her where did he live to create a
dark wave of skin but yeah that'd be an
interesting one to follow what would you
like to say to fans the show fans of
yours on the show as well here watching
this video out there thank you again
you know since the last time we spoke
and thank you again for all the support
it's amazing too
to get all the feedback you guys give me
and these events are such a joy because
actually getting to meet something as as
what makes it all worth er so thank you
you know I hope to hope to keep giving
you up that you enjoy watching
you